t merci là par l'état monsieur claude
degano merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
à défaut d'aller mieux ou d'être en
marche la france constate tristement vos
échecs vos promesses révolue et les
déclarations contradictoires au sein
même de votre gouvernement
quoi de mieux pour illustrer cet état de
fait que la récente déclaration du chef
de l'état concernant la réduction
arbitraires de la part du nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique de 75 à 50% d'ici
2025 la fermeture programmée d'une
partie du parc nucléaire n'interviendra
finalement qu'après avis rendu par
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
à la fin de l'année 2018 comment
qualifier ce report
si ce n'est un enterrement en bonne et
due forme d'une promesse de campagne
inconséquente malgré les avertissements
des professionnels du secteur et les
vives mises en garde venant de notre
banc vous avez persisté dans cette
direction fragilisant durablement la
troisième filière industrielle française
comment ne pas relier les difficultés
d'edf d'areva et des nombreuses
entreprises sous traitantes à cette
décision qui relève d'une faute
stratégique majeure je n'ose imaginer
que vous n'étiez pas conscient que cette
réduction viendrait à menacer plus de
40000 emplois directs et mettre à mal
une activité économique essentiel pour
nos territoires ruraux
déjà durement affecté par la crise
économique
rénover notre industrie nucléaire est
une nécessité
je vous la corde mais l'a précipitée
vers sa fin ne serait que dogmatisme
monsieur le premier ministre
profiterez vous de ce report pour
redéfinir une politique énergétique
d'avenir fondée sur un mix énergétique
pragmatique et ainsi stopper
l'hémorragie qui remet en cause la
crédibilité du nucléaire tricolore du
crédit lillers a dit si la parole est à
monsieur emmanuel macron ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
fait d'abord vous annoncer une nouvelle
ce que le président de la république a
en effet confirmé la semaine dernière
c'est un engagement de campagne
c'est ce qui a été traduit dans la loi
de transition énergétique et c'est ce
qui sera mise en oeuvre
c'est précisément la réduction de la
dépendance du mix énergétique français à
l'égard du nucléaire
et quand on regarde les exemples
internationaux entend entre autres
l'exemple japonais
c'est une bonne chose mais c'est le
faire en bon ordre et au bon rythme
c'est à dire précisément avec une
programmation qui sera présenté d'ici
l'été sans sacrifier des emplois sans
fragiliser notre souveraineté
énergétique et c'est ce qui a été
confirmé par le président de la
république ce que ségolène royal
également avait pu dire parce qu'on ne
ferme pas une centrale du jour au
lendemain
maintenant une fois qu'on a dit ça et
j'entends les déclarations d'amour
parfois tardive à l'égard du nucléaire
français le nucléaire français il ne
suffit pas de l'aimer il faut bien
l'organiser il faut le protéger il faut
le prévoir il faut avoir une politique
de long terme c'est à dire une politique
industrielle
et c'est bien ce que fait ce
gouvernement dans le cadre d'une
pratique responsable
oui monsieur le député je suis au regret
de vous le dire parce que les
difficultés qui existent aujourd'hui
chez areva
chez edf on trouve parfois sur certains
sites industriels
j'étais encore en début de semaine au
creusot ça n'est pas le résultat de la
transition énergétique
c'est le résultat d'un marché nucléaire
mondial qui s'est profondément
transformé après fukushima
c'est le résultat d'un marché
énergétique qui a été profondément
bousculé par le gaz de schiste et c'est
le fait que l'état a été un actionnaire
est un stratège défaillant pendant
plusieurs années en prélevant
essentiellement des dividendes et en
considérant qu'il n'y avait pas de
cohérence à voir dans cette filière
la refondation de la filière nucléaire
c'est ce qui accompagne la transition
énergétique
c'est notre politique à l'égard du
nucléaire c'est fermé